oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est temps d'accueillir
nos deux invités du soir jean pierre
foucault y sylvie tellier
la femme est plus avec douceur
comparable
ils sont tous la vie ces sortes abou
hourayra pas un qui ose quoique sk non
non c'est toi lola jean pierre poupon
qui m'a enlevé la perruque
c'est vraiment choisir seulement ma
soeur et ben voila ce coup des voix donc
voilà j'ai fait les chemises rouges
après la teinture ou d'accueil de ces
bouteilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que tu viens de fontenay vous
manque si elle me ment oui c'est pas
c'est pas la question d'un concours miss
france ou humainement d'accord d'accord
j'entends lembras j'aime bien vous allez
pouvoir l'embrasser en vrai geneviève
jean pierre foucault devait se déguiser
en geneviève de fontenay sans rigoler je
viens de voir un aperçu castellas classe
et là attention
geneviève de fontenay et jean pierre
foucault était avec nous sur le plateau
un peu d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
je manque pas la teignouse en clair mais
jean-pierre mais ça vous va super bien
de vous présentez pas comme ça non c'est
flippant en grève à à ma femme s'appelle
maurice un peu mais jean-pierre je me
fais un bisou à fait exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]